quero falar agora sobre o Vasco,
com mais uma,
mais um reforço engatilhado.
depois de fechar a contratação do Adson,
Vasco
define os últimos detalhes da transferência de força lá.
volante
só vinte anos de idade,
vinte e um anos de idade pra ser mais preciso,
pertence ao newshold boys.
entre Vasco e news tá tudo certo.
$quatro milhões de OU dezenove milhões dereais
por 80% dos direitos económicos.
os clubes
discutem as últimas minutos do contrato antes da
oficialização do acordo.
pra quem não conhece o esforço,
volante revelado no news
com passagens por todas as categorias de base
da seleção Argentina.
na seleção,
inclusive,
era capitão
na temporada passada,
chegou a fazer um gol no Santos,
na Vila Belmiro,
no confronto entre news e Santos pela sul americana,
vitória do news por dois a um.